hey talk about um because you were
supposed to go on tour with russ
and russ is one of those guys that like
i feel like
he gets he gets some some negative
feedback because i feel like people
think he's a little arrogant but i
i take it the other way i take it like
yo this guy's
he kind of knows what he's talking about
and i always noticed
that he reaches out to artists it
doesn't matter necessarily because he's
you know he's a big artist
but he just reaches out to artists that
he [ __ ] with that he's a fan of no
matter
what the case is and when i saw him put
you on his album
this was at the beginning of the year um
and then put you on the road with him i
was like that's so
dope like because that's gonna bring
your movement to so many
random kids who never heard of you talk
about you and russ's relationship
can't nobody tell me [ __ ] about russ you
know what i'm saying
okay nobody tell me [ __ ] about russ just
you said it
you didn't have to do none of that and
you know what i mean and me i'm a
i'm a street [ __ ] so when you do things
like that
for me that calls for uh
for loyalty you for what i'm saying
because he didn't have to do that so i
only know how to
i only know how to like react to certain
[ __ ] like that in certain ways like
keep putting food on the table for my
family he providing opportunities for me
and my [ __ ] right here so me being
from where i'm from like that calls for
loyalty you can't you think tell me [ __ ]
about russ man he a good dude